Elizabeth is in Dallas Texas hi
Elizabeth how are you I'm good how are
you
better than I deserve what's up I was
wondering I'm on very sub 2 and I'm
having the hardest time to get my
husband to begin the debt snowball with
me because he doesn't want to pay the
minimum on every debt every month he
just lays it off he says all the whole
payback six months it is the hardest
thing it's like pulling teeth how old is
he 25 how long has he been this air
responsible he says this after we got
married I think it was before cuz I mean
you don't pay your payments that's just
irresponsible if you have the money yeah
yes that's not a debt snowball thing
that's just like called paying your
bills that's being in a dull yes okay
like our house bills but he doesn't want
to pay our credit card every month like
that's the one thing he's like he'll
Wade that off right Oh
fine how long y'all been married almost
two years what what's he do for a living
he is he works for a loan company he's a
manager hmm let's come in just a minute
yeah what are the people of the people
that other people that owed his company
money just paid it whatever they wanted
hey no that's what he comes on me got
some some won't pay their loan this
month okay well you're doing this thing
oh it's frustrating frustrating I I
don't think this is a financial problem
I don't I think it's a maturity problem
all right
and so then I can see that you are
frustrated so I think
you know a man or a woman that just
won't pay their bills just because they
are irresponsible and just don't bother
that's just means they haven't grown up
yet or that doesn't matter if they're 55
or they're 25 that's what they're facing
and so um I don't know how to help
somebody grow up exactly oh I'm trying
to think if one of my daughters came in
and sat down told me this about one of
my sons in law what I would do and that
would never happen but if it did what
would I suggest to them or or one of my
nieces you know or somebody like that
that's your age because my kids are your
age you know so if they came in and said
this I would first thing I'd best become
sad I think because I think you guys are
going to struggle until he deals with
his irresponsibility um mm-hmm
yeah so you know I think I think what I
would tell them is to make sure that the
two of you are in a good Church and that
maybe you try to find some older wise an
older wiser couple in that church that
would kind of come alongside you and
coach you about life about about your
marriage
about you know just your career just
kind of be there for you some people
that have got a few scars because
they've done a few dumb things you know
and that we just love you and kind of be
there and walk with you and that that he
would trust and you would trust to go to
with questions and with problems and and
you know you could just sit and talk to
them about something like this you could
do that that would work or you if you
were going to a good church you could
sit down with a pastor the two of you
and say you know pastor this has
bothered me about him and
and I just think it's wrong and I can't
seem to get through to him can you help
me with that or am I wrong and then I
think pastor I look at him and knock a
knot on his head if it's a good pastor
because that's what he needs am i
knocking out on his head might loves him
enough to go man up buddy
man up cause you're just acting like
you're freaking four years old you know
you could be a little nicer than that I
don't have to be because I'm on the
radio but pastor would be nicer right
and you're still just loving somebody
well and telling them the truth so that
they can move to a better place in their
life because I want good things for him
he just want to grow up to get them hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Music]